un certain nombre de
propriétés biologiques ont des
conséquences sociales
immédiates donc c'est pas de
l'explication par le biologiqu pas du
tout mais des propriétés biologiques que
nous avons vont
déterminer des propriétés qui sont
parfaitement social et étudiable comme
disait Durkheim le social explique le
social il faut expliquer le social par
rien d'autre que le social mais ce qu'il
faut rajouter c'est que il y a des
conditions pour que ce social existe
comme il existe c'est-à-dire structuré
comme il est structuré et cette
altricialité secondaire que j'ai décrit
comme une dépendance à l'égard des
parents en fait c'est une expérience
universelle de tous les petits humains
et en fait c'est c'est une expérience de
la domination c'estàdire c'est les
rapports parent-enfant euh même quand
ils sont extrêmement bienveillants sont
des rapports de domination c'estàd les
parents ont évidemment beaucoup plus de
pouvoir que les enfants